The joe rogan experience.
Oh,
I still feel a big,
big difference from these and the clinical trial that we did,
the double blind that was with this,
this particular formula,
but I still think that we should release a fucking hyper version for people are
savages.
Oh,
you want to get crazy?
Even if you don't want her own calling crossbones on it.
If we can't release it,
can I at least get some
combination?
We can get you something.
Well,
I think this is just the beginning of this sort of science of a,
of nootropics and they're coming up with all sorts of different combinations.
These things Paratha town.
I want that stuff to be like in Olean.
Oh,
that shit limitless.
I love that movie,
man.
That's America in a nutshell.
Everybody's wants to be a lazy fuck that you take a pill and then set your
suits.
Gotta work for it though.
Isn't it funny though how many God damn movies there are about a dumb person all
sudden become super smart and figures the whole fucking world out?
Yeah,
like John Travolta when you got hit by lightning.
That's right.
All the sudden these fucking learning Portuguese and shit.
Yeah,
that was a good one.
[inaudible] was outside with the polar turning gets struck by lightning and
stuff.
So like it'd be smarter.
Well,
you know what does work with some things like people have,
like I have a friend and her son got in a motorcycle accident and then he got a
head injury and became super artistic after the motorcycle injury.
Yeah.
So we do need to get hit in the head.
Well [inaudible] science,
that's the problem.
Sam Kinison got hit and they had a,
when he was a kid too,
he got hit by a truck.
Oh,
I heard about this.
Yeah.
And it fucking switch.
You'd be like a normal,
calm,
shy kid.
And then he got hit by a truck and Sinai.
He became this fucking wild,
impulsive maniac.
That's crazy.
Honestly.
Yeah.
What head injuries are just very strange.
It's very strange.
The reactions that a,
that had her injuries have,
you know,
people have had car accidents and then become gay.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
Really no way.
I might have.
I might have made that at all.
No,
I did.
Hold on a second.
The head trauma turns it up.
No,
I don't think so.
Some guy who was,
who was gay and just use that as an excuse.
That's fine.
I'm not judging it.
Rugby player wakes up gay after a stroke.
Wow.
He had a stroke and then he woke up and he was gay.
Someone took care of him when he was barely rugby player has a stroke after
freak gym,
accident up gay and becomes a hairdresser.
That's just as exciting to me.
Whatever.
I mean he's gained again.
It's cool.
Whatever.
You know this is actually earlier but so does not look
like a rugby player either.
But I mean he doesn't even make up an excuse of getting hit in the head to be
game and just whoever your gates.
Okay.
You don't know.
Maybe really did have a stroke and woke up gay,
but he used to look like straight as fuck.
He looked straight.
Well,
you know,
there was um,
there was a drug called reequip that uh,
an Irish man won a settlement of,
I believe it was like 600,000 US dollars because this drug turned him gay.
And into a addict.
She was having unsafe sex and he was,
uh,
he was going like meeting people online and getting fucking crazy with dudes and
do it.
A bunch of gay shit.
And he was a family man.
Married.
Got One.
He Won.
How do you prove that?
That's a very good question.
Tj.
Dillashaw yeah.
I like how you think fucking know,
man.
But not only did they prove it,
I mean,
this was against Glaxo Klein to Glaxo Klein Smith,
the big pharmaceutical companies.
They're the ones who lost.
So it was their lawyers lost this case.
It was so much evidence here,
I'll pull it up.
Re-Equip this.
There must be so much fucking evidence.
Turns a man Gai.
Wow.
That is crazy.
There's so much evidence that they actually had to give him money,
which was an amazing,
yeah,
you want 160,000 pounds,
which is roughly somewhere around,
what's the,
that weird looking thing?
It's not a pound.
I have no,
the one shore.
I think so.
Um,
anyway,
whatever the,
the,
the amount this was,
it was a lot of,
even if it was $160,000,
way too much.
He doesn't care if it's 160 bucks,
he shouldn't get paid for them.
Somebody's got,
somebody's got the manipulators.
Well,
he had Parkinson's and so this was a Parkinson's medication and it turned him
into a gay sex and gambling addict.
Amazing impulsive control systems.
And this is where it gets really weird,
including compulsive behaviors.
There have been reports of patients experiencing intense urges to gamble,
increased sexual urges and other intense urges and the inability to control
those urges while taking one or more of the medications that increase central
dope.
Dope.
It dope.
Amid Magenta,
manured,
JIC dopaminergic Dopa magick menergy tones that are generally used for the
treatment of Parkinson's disease.
So this is an restless leg syndrome or when you see when dudes like can't stop
moving their legs.
It's my parking guy.
Does he have any daughters?
Is that a job?
Should have worked on that one a little bit more for you.
Let it loose skin sons.
He had Parkinson's.
Oh,
you're so retarded.
It doesn't work.
He can't keep trying.
He's like,
come on guys.
Parking son wears his daughters.
When I get it,
they lot to fuck.
I thought it was funny,
but I think you missed it.
Please don't encourage him.
We both had it.
There was nothing there.
The um,
the idea that a,
that a drug could do that too though is pretty fucking shocking,
is the drug that turns you into acting like a lot of other people in the world.
Well,
not just acting like a lot of the people in the world,
but you were a normal guy,
was a control of your urges and then all of a sudden you're just flying off the
handle meet and dudes online.
They're just,
there you go,
Brian.
We should do that as a test.
Just get you on this shit.
I would love to try it.
He would totally do it.
He'd be the best Guinea pig.
Give him a monthly budget and a videographer and a nice,
it would be a delight Dick.
It'd be,
that's thing in the rural if you just craved it instead of having to do with all
this nonsense.
That's what I'm saying.
Back at the gym,
dammit.
I mean,
look,
everybody wants to say there's something wrong with being gay,
but you live and you die.
And if you're straight,
you look at gang go,
oh,
I don't want that.
But guess what?
If you're straight,
you look at,
you know,
if you're gay,
rather you look at straight and go,
I don't want that.
What you like is what you like.
And if you like gay,
it would be awesome to be gay.
There's spots.
I had doctors and had to go do my physicals and stuff for the fight and they
say,
why are you fighting?
Like,
why are you doing this?
Like fuck man,
I don't know.
But it's fun.
Yeah.
I rent my levels of testosterone,
I think,
well,
if you go down to Santa Monica Boulevard,
if you're a gay guy,
there's like a one stop shop.
You just,
you just take your shirt off and just walk to the crowd and to just start
blowing.
You mean?
That's what I hear.
That's what I hear very different because it's all Yang because Yang Yang,
Yang,
Yang.
There's no Yin's like there's no like,
oh,
I don't know.
You just want to use me.
None of that.
They're using each other.
They just fucking blasting each other.
They're having a great time.
They understand each other.
There's no confusion.
There's no navigate.
Navigating relationship with a woman is like putting rubber gloves on in the
dark and putting your hands into one of those incubation tubes and try to do a
Rubik's cube.
Like what?
I can't see.
What's Fuck's going on here?
You have to like take their word for what is happening here.
Oh,
you're upset that I went out with my friends.
okay.
I guess.
No more friends and you my friend.
How are you?
What's going on here?
That's you.
We don't know how they think.
I think I got a good Rubik's cube.
Yeah.
I was like,
dude,
you got a good one.
That's the key.
Get a Rubik's cube that you can figure out.
But dudes,
no one dudes,
they're like,
Oh,
you like Dick guy like pod
fucking.
They know what's going on.
I was like,
we both like each other.
They Bang it out.
It seems more easy.
You were offered this drug.
If you weren't married,
would you try it?
You know,
I'd have to be committed because women can dance back and forth from the world
of gay and straight with an effortless finesse.
They can,
they can easily go back and forth.
Not only that,
it makes them more attractive.
They can say things like,
[inaudible] like to talk about this,
but I was gay for like a year,
shut up for a year.
I had a girlfriend and you know,
I just,
just like,
men are assholes,
I'm done.
And you're like,
your dick is like just a raging feel missile than your parents
where she tell her to come stay with us.
You know?
That's the first thought in every guy for sure.
For sure.
She's like,
it's okay.
It doesn't even bother me.
If you came home and you find your girlfriend eating pussy,
you wouldn't be like,
what the fuck?
You'd be like,
oh,
what's going on here?
Just take your clothes off and come in the room like,
hey,
as long as the girls,
the girlfriend is not like all jealous and fucking plotty,
Jamie,
you better keep it away from me.
Oh God.
Someone's ruin the party
as long as she's friendly too.
Oh boy.
But if a girl comes home and her boyfriend is stuck in a car,
that's a bummer.
You come home and your boyfriend is blown.
The plumber that is a fucking straight bummer,
you know?
But if you came home and like,
you know,
your wife had went to fucking lunch with some chick was in aerobics class and
they're eating each other out when you walked through the door.
It's really not that big of a deal.
It's a little surprising.
Like,
Whoa,
this is crazy.
Yeah.
The act of two male sex is a very different act.
It's very,
so no,
I wouldn't take that pill
to answer your question.
Yeah.
Would you take it?
You think you would take it?
No,
no,
no.
It's pretty,
girls are better.
They're pretty,
or they smell better.
Would be interesting to try it though.
If there was a a a serum,
you know what I mean?
Like,
oh my God,
I liked Dick.
That's so weird.
All right,
nevermind.
That was weird.
Yeah.
I wouldn't mind curious just to see how cool.
I wouldn't mind being that girl for a day.
This is what I say.
If I was,
if I,
if there is a possibility that you could go into someone's mind,
like say this,
say if you,
you and your girlfriend got together and you went into a machine and you swapped
positions.
Like she became the girl and you became the guy.
Like you had all your knowledge of life,
but all of a sudden you thought like a girl and you wanted to get fucked and you
want to get fucked by you because she's,
you know,
and you are her.
So you liked boys and you liked you and like that would be a way that you could
be gay but not be gay because you'd be gay for yourself.
So you would switch positions with your girlfriend or,
or why you have her thoughts and she would be banging you doggy style.
You're like,
wow,
this does hurt my servant.
This is kind of annoying.
She wasn't lying.
She could be you.
She can feel what it's like to get head and go,
oh,
now I know why you're always trying to get me to do this.
This is pretty awesome.
She's like,
it's odd.
I like it better when I'm looking at it crazy.
I like it better when I'm looking at you doing this.
I never would have imagined that.
Now I know why you're always creeping me out.
They didn't.
I need to invent this machine just to make the relationship better and make
everyone's relationship.
Well,
there's a problem now man,
this,
this weird competition between men and women.
There's US versus them,
you know,
and there's a bunch of sneaky fucks that sneak on the other side,
both men and women.
This is a bunch of women that's down to hang with men.
You know,
this is a girl.
She like to come over your house and no,
she can watch sports with us.
The fuck she can.
Goddamn trader,
gender trader over here,
sneaking around,
collecting data to bring back to the enemy.
Yeah.
Okay.